[Music]
this man also known as the worst
president in United States history loves
ice cream lounging on beaches and
sniffing
children
Joe uh who is me wait where am
I hello people live once again from the
free state of Florida in the best city
in the world Miami I'm Dave ruin this is
the Ruben report it's February 7th 2024
that's right we survived a day in the
swamp I'll tell you a bit about the trip
in just a moment uh as always we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals postgame show Ruben report.
locals.com I should note everybody that
as of yesterday we crossed one billion
video views on YouTube uh obviously we
want the majority of you guys to watch
on Rumble Andor locals uh if you can and
and I think if you have the internet you
should be able to uh but that is quite a
quite a moment a billion views that's an
awful lot of views that's pretty great
and as I've mentioned a couple times in
the last week or so just every day where
just we're just crushing every record
that we have so I appreciate that you
guys appreciate a little decency and
honesty and maybe a little comedy with
your news um real quick on the on the DC
trip where we interviewed ran Paul and
Jim Jordan at the capital and Ted Cruz
and Maria Blackburn and we got to wander
around and see all the usual stuff I
have to say it was a bit of an odd day
uh to be there because there's two real
themes happening in DC at the moment uh
one of them very specifically to to
what's happening right now is this is
this border deal which is completely DOA
it's not going to happen a lot of
nonsensical fighting about it as you
guys know Biden already has the power to
do something about the Border we already
have laws about the Border this is just
more nonsense and more money for Ukraine
and everything else but there was a real
sense from all of the politicians that I
talk to and and almost everyone that I
talk to everywhere like none of it works
like sort of just like nothing is really
working there and I think that'll kind
of get us to the theme today and then of
course the second thing was just every
time anyone brings up anything about Joe
Biden it's like everyone's basically
like can you believe this can you
believe that this is still continuing
like the man something is not right with
this guy and we're all just pretending
that he should be president or that he's
actually running the country or doing
anything or is is the driving
intellectual force behind this
Administration which is all complete
nonsense so I suppose uh today we will
peer behind that curtain and see what's
really going on uh I'm going to connect
that to some of the Dei stuff and uh and
a bunch more you know we've shown you a
couple videos in the last few weeks of
Mark Cuban Mark Cuban of course from
Shark Tank Tech billionaire owns the
Dallas Mavericks and he's gone really
all in on pushing for Dei and the weird
thing about it is that more and more
people are pushing back against Dei now
like people are realizing that racism
against anyone even white people or even
Jews or even Asians uh that that
actually is bad but Cuban keeps diving
in on it and the more he Dives in on it
the more he's going after Elon Musk and
Twitter and then we're going to connect
that to how when you have a series of
bad ideas like Dei like neoism that you
can actually kind of Dent Dent if not do
irreparable damage to a country that was
founded on the ideas of freedom and
liberty and individual rights that we've
allowed the monster into the house the
monster has done a whole bunch of damage
and it is time to kick the monster out
and start cleaning up the house uh and I
think if you do that you might start
thinking for yourself you might start
putting some of the pieces together and
live a good life let's see what happens
here so over the weekend uh Mark Cuban
was at a conference claiming that ex
users who are pushing back against him
uh for defending Dei well surprise
surprise they're anti-semites you know
social media has changed it's no longer
social and since Twitter became X
I mean like I I was telling you you mean
like when I get Juwan I get you're not
white you're you're Jewish um I get tell
the Jew to shut the up I you know and I
just bookmark them Twitter has become
just a cesspool for haes and so trying
to go there and change people's mind I
mean I've seen people try and then
everybody just gangs up and Instagram
just people avoid it and then same with
linkoln it's just not that platform
social media I don't see as being that
place I think you've got to go face to
face you know i' you know i' I'd rather
that's why when I have these
conversations I go where I know people
are going to disagree with me you know
whether it's Dei or whatever all right
so first off you guys know I like to
give the devil is due how many times on
this show have I said that social media
has not made us more social it has made
us more antisocial there is something to
be said for that right we stare at our
phones constantly uh we are not
connecting with real people we now know
that young people are have are full with
anxiety and suicidal thoughts and
confused about their gender and all
those things so all of that is kind of
right social media has done something
very weird to us I suppose when
sociologists 100 years from now look
back at the time from say around 2002 to
right around now they're going to be
like boy that was a weird time where
humans really kind of flipped into the
digital world and spent more time
staring at a screen than living in real
life and all of those things so that
that's legit now related to the hate
thing there is a ton of hate online I
you're not going to believe this guys
people say mean things about Dave Rubin
every single day mostly most of them
work for me but even online they say
mean things and it is what it is they
make they'll attack you for your
religion they'll attack you for your
gender for your sexuality all of those
things the idea that it's somehow worse
under Elon I don't think there's any
empirical evidence of that but no one's
forcing anyone to be on any of these
platforms also this idea that like
you're not white you're Jewish I mean
sort of fits in with the Dei thing that
he is defending I mean what what has so
many people annoyed at Mark Cuban right
now is he keeps defending saying that he
wants to use the ideas of Dei in his
companies and that he does which
actually might get him in legal trouble
because you are not allowed to
discriminate again against anyone based
on skin color Etc when hiring uh he made
a point a couple days ago on Twitter to
say something about if you had a a room
of 30 black women would that be a great
idea to company and it's like well I'm
pretty sure not all black women think
think the exact same thing do you think
that Candice Owens and say Sunny hoston
think the same thing so they happen to
both be black like work this through
with me Cuban anyway so yes Cuban
getting a lot of hate because people
push back on bad ideas and yes there are
Bad actors and Anonymous people and say
people say mean things that has led him
to now block Elon Musk on Twitter I
always looked at Dei as being positive
and I effectively said that in some
posts on on
Twitter Elon called me a racist Mark
cubin is a
racist so I thought for a while I'm like
okay what should I say back what should
I say back what should I say back you
just said I mean you started replying to
my question you said I want to mess up I
wanted to Alon I want to mess up
with him I mean this is a really it's
it's a massive platform to just prank a
friend platform it's like walking into
someone else's house or restaurant right
and saying you know I know this is your
game and it's all your rules but you
know I thought about it for a minute and
I said okay there's only one thing I
could really do that would send the
message I wanted to send so I blocked
them he can take it off no he can remove
the I don't know I don't know if he has
right I don't care but um oh you blocked
him he makes a point now calling people
racist it doesn't really get most of us
anywhere but they had been going back
and forth for quite some time we covered
some of it on the show at the end of the
day uh racism against white people is
bad racism against Jews against Asian
people racism against any group of
people is bad Mark Cuban is saying that
he uses the ideas of Dei in his
companies to hire now we brought up the
point and many other people did and by
the way before you know he keep saying
that all these people are saying mean
things to him I saw tons and tons of
people like Libs of Tik Tock and Chris
rufo and some other people we're going
to talk about later on the show and and
myself included who were respectfully
reaching out to him and saying actually
Mark you're a little confused as to what
Dei is and how they are using the word
equity in a way that you don't think
they're using the word equity and
everything else so the question is who
are the real racists is it the people
that are pushing Dei or is it someone
like Elon Musk who wants a society built
on meritocracy and everything else and
Elon Musk who by the way is uh
African-American and treated quite
poorly by the mainstream media we'll get
to that on the other side let me talk to
you guys about truly office guys are you
a listener of the Ruben report who
values digital Independence and privacy
truly office.com hears you that's why
they're offering a special 30% offer our
audience truly office is more than an
office suite it's a statement against
the mainstream Tech narrative no ads no
tracking only privacy how will that
change the way you work at an average
truly office is saving an average
American 82% off their yearly
subscription costs of
$24 one-time payment versus $149 for the
bloatware the guys at Microsoft charge
us every year on a monthly subscription
use code Rumble 30 at truly office.com
Rumble and take control of your digital
workspace today and now back to me okay
so again when I when I play these clips
of Elon and Mark cubin or Bill Mah or
Joe Rogan some of these guys it's like
what's the point of talking about these
people it's not exactly what's happening
in the political world but politics is
Downstream from culture these are the
taste makers that get everything going
on in the world right so a quick tweet
from uh Elon Musk about all exactly what
we're discussing right here Dei is
racist and sexist and of course it is if
you hire somebody or don't hire somebody
based on the color of their skin or
their gender or their sexuality it is
but don't take my word for it what is
the definition of the word racism could
we get that up there this is on Google
itself racism Prejudice discrimination
or antagonism by an individual Community
or institution against a person or
people on the basis of their membership
in a particular racial or ethnic group
typically one that is a minority or
marginalized uh I do want to make note
that the last part of that typically one
that is a minority or marginalized that
seems like a bit of a new version of a
definition of racism if you see a bunch
of white people over there and you're
like those white honkies I'm not going
to
you're racist if you see a bunch of
Asian kids and you're like you know what
I work at Harvard and I'm going to make
them work a lot harder and have much
higher grades and we're going to take
way less of them than say a bunch of
black students you're racist if
you uh are an administrator at
University of Pennsylvania let's say and
you're like yes yes they can chant to
kill all the Jews you're still racist so
this this oppression part and this
minority part also shows you how
Insidious all this is um interestingly
Mark hbin who owns the Dallas Mavericks
he apparently doesn't use Dei when it
comes to hiring uh basketball players
what were the numbers on that there are
18 current players on the Mavericks and
I and two only two are white so that
really does make it's almost as if when
it really matters and you're really
doing something based on skill that uh
Dei out the window but speaking of the
NBA uh the WNBA which is the women's
basketball league I'm a big fan you know
uh they had this little conference on
how they're doing diversity hiring over
there I thought you might enjoy this
yeah absolutely um I think a lot of our
teams are really doing a great job and
and there's been a focus from the league
to help push diversity hiring practices
um when Co particularly when coaching
and um front office vacancies occur um
so there is a diversity hiring task
force that's taken place and sorry that
that has been kind of of uh organized I
guess for lack of a better term um and
so the work there is to try to make sure
we have better representation of people
of color people of various kind of
gender experiences if you will um in
these roles we definitely need people of
various gender experiences that's a new
one for me gender what what are you
experiencing gender-wise today Connor
still male still you're consistent
that's why we keep you around um first
off that woman is white and it's like
lady stop telling me show me step down
and get me a gender queer black woman up
there because come on lady it's enough
it's enough uh also if they really care
about diversity at the WNBA find a
straight woman to play in that League
they're all Lesbos that's just how it is
okay I don't mean that to be racist or
any anything else it's a lot of lesbians
we should we need to think about that
and get more straight women playing in
the w we should have some dudes playing
in the WNBA that would be diverse anyway
if you want to see how the the level of
of it's it's stupidity but it's it's
dangerous stupidity right that that
infects virtually everything when it
comes to Dei and this
neoism uh here's mayor Eric Adams from
New York once great city a city I lived
in that at times there were times in the
in the uh mid 1900s that my family had
over 100 family members living in New
York City I have one cousin left
everybody has fled there are no reubin
left in New York City and I'm pretty
sure that cousin doesn't talk to me
because she's a lefty nutbag which is
why she stayed anyway um Eric Adams uh
he's very very excited because even
though there's crime it's rampant and
the Migra the migrants are destroying
the city and businesses have fled and
all the rich people are leaving and all
of that stuff uh the important thing is
uh he's got a lot of black people in his
administration stand up they need to see
you Deputy Mayor Williams isim Deputy
Mayor miror Josie Deputy Mayor amazar
Deputy man Maria Torres
Springer have you ever seen this much
chocolate leading the city of New
York and then go down the line look look
who's here this is representative of the
city that's why people are hating on
me you trying to figure out
out why they hating on me they hating on
me because those how many you go to
church ma'am this is a Matthew 21-12
moment Jesus walked in the temple he saw
them doing wrong in the temple he did
what he turned the table over I went to
City Hall and turn the table
over first women Police Commissioner of
color first Spanish speaking Police
Commissioner first Spanish speaking uh
uh correction Comm
commissioner go through the line of what
we're do there is so much Insanity there
they're attacking him because he's
turning the the board and all the people
he works with into chocolate first off I
just want to say I'm very proud of the
white chocolate that we have in this
room white white white white asian back
there which again why we keep the Asian
guy in a separate room we're working on
it we're working on it it's we're a big
company here it takes things to to get
through the system
anyway he tells you how diverse and
great and how proud he is of his
chocolate there's 23% of New York City
is black so he's telling you about the
diversity while showing you all of these
black people I don't care that they're
black it doesn't matter are any of these
people capable are any of these people
competent is the black female police
chief competent no it's Absol and then
he Compares himself to Jesus Jesus H
Christ what are we doing what are we
doing so okay and then and then of
course what it all boils down to really
at the end is does this man uh do his
job properly does the does the system
function so imagine if New York City was
thriving right now imagine if all there
there was there was all this economic
activity there were they were building
things uh industries were coming in uh
people felt safe on the streets there
weren't drugs and homeless and
everything well then I guess if I was
complaining about all this stuff you
might be like Dave enough like it it's
working but everywhere that these ideas
take root it it destroys pretty much
everything and by the way that is now
being it is being literally federalized
it is being exported throughout the
entire country check this out from the
libs of Tik Tock account this is a
current job listing for an onair traffic
controller on the faa's website uh
they're saying that it's open to people
with disabilities including psychiatric
and intellectual delays uh and as she
wrote doesn't it make you feel safe
knowing your air traffic controller can
have an intellectual disability or have
a seizure while directing your flight
Dei will get people killed literally if
you look at some of the highlights there
it includes speech impediment what is
that psychiatric disorders severe
psychiatric disorders this is insane and
as we talk about all the time and
Charlie Kirk got in a lot of trouble
with about this a couple weeks ago with
some of the mainstream media people if
you say to a certain set of people you
can be less qualified to get into this
school and you can be less qualified to
get into the grad school and you can be
less qualified to get the job after that
and etc etc and then move up the ranks
once you have the job you will you will
slowly degrade the entire system planes
will fall out of the sky surgeons won't
know how to perform surgery you're going
to have literally a person with a
psychiatric disorder who also has
trouble speaking trying to explain to a
plane why they shouldn't land because
there's a plane on the runway already
but that is what it we are doing so let
me connect that of course to what was up
top so up top was Mark Cuban basically
saying he is getting hate because he is
for Dei and Dei is not discrimination I
think we've laid out the case many times
on this show that Dei actually is uh
what discrimination is all about it's
Neo discrimination you know masked in
well we're nice and diverse and all of
those things but the truth is once you
are on the side of Dei you are the ones
that are on the side of hate and I'm
going to lay that out after I talk to
you about ramp guys running a business
is tricky and you have to stay on top of
every little detail across expenses
payments and accounting who can you use
to make or or who you use can make or
break you and you need the best ramp is
a complete Game Changer and saves you
time from getting trapped in busy work
while maximizing productivity and
cutting wasteful spending ramp is a
corporate card and spend management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket in
fact businesses that use ramp save an
average of 5% in the first year while
using them with ramp you're able to
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
they're also easy to use issue virtual
and physical cards and start making
payments in less than 15 minutes where
they have five employees or 5,000
employees ramp will save you time and
money get $250 when you join ramp today
go to ramp.com rubben that's rm.com
rubben cards issued by Sutton Bank and
Celtic Bank members FDIC terms and
conditions apply and now back to me so
just real quick in case you forgot where
we started on this show let me show you
a condensed clip of Mark cubin
explaining where Hate's coming from
these days when I get Juwan I get you're
not white you're you're Jewish um I get
tell the Jew to shut the up I you
know and I just bookmark them Twitter
has become just a cesspool for hate why
why would you bookmark them if someone
told me to go f myself you think I want
to bookmark that so I can go look at it
later like I'm about to go to bed who
who told me to go f myself today uh but
okay so he is the guy defending Dei and
then he's saying boy look at the mean
things that people say to me because I'm
defending Dei well how about we actually
look at the real results of once Dei
becomes institutionalized I think you'll
recognize former Harvard president Claud
Dean gay at her wonderful Congressional
hearing when she couldn't decide whether
calling for the death of Jews was good
or not and Dr Gay at Harvard does
calling for the genocide of Jews VI
viate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no anti-semitic
rhetoric when it anti-semitic rhetoric
anti-semitic rhetoric when it crosses
into conduct that amounts to bullying
harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action that line that
line I know you've heard it a million
times but that line to say when it
crosses into conduct is one of the
craziest things ever again this had
nothing to do with the first Amendment
right it wasn't about the government
stopping anyone from speaking this was
about Harvard applying their own uh
policies uh related to speech and how
students are supposed to treat each
other and it was only when it crosses
into the once we when you have just
killed a couple Jews now we're going to
have a real meeting over this thing uh
but anyway the point of that clip was to
show you that yes it is not nice that
people say mean things about Mark Cuban
and I'm sure when he is swimming in his
billions it's probably very upsetting
there's no doubt about that like I wish
we had a clip of uh Scrooge McDuck
swimming in his billions could we get
Cuban's head on him dve remember he dive
into the cash um that that's one thing
that's upsetting but the point is that
the very idea that he's defending the
ideas of Dei look what they do once they
are institutionalized we know exactly
what they've done at places like Harvard
virtually all of our places of Higher
Learning and then what does that do it
leaks out so you have a brainwashed
generation of young people who are out
on the streets supporting Hamas a
genocidal uh terrorist organization that
is doing far worse things than the
people who are saying mean things to
Mark cubin and then of course we also
elect leaders who are all in on these
terrible idea so I want to show you uh a
clip just from yesterday Congress we
have uh two of the Premier members of
the Hamas caucus here's Rashida Talib
and AOC and uh well just listen to some
of their I mean this is just psychotic
rhetoric but these are people whose
Minds have been muddled by the oppressed
depressor narrative here we go again
again sending $17.6 billion US tax
dollars with no conditions attached to
netanyahu's extremist government to drop
more bombs on innocent Palestinians the
Israeli government has already killed
27,000 people 11,500 of them were
children I'm tired of my colleagues
coming to me Whispering I don't really
like Netanyahu well then why are we
sending him billions of dollars with no
conditions he literally has telling us
over and over again what his intention
his so I'm tired I oppose netanyahu's
war crimes and want him gone too but
many of my colleagues that contined to
tell me that do not want a condition to
Aid they give it to a genocidal Maniac I
think the chair Mr Speaker more than
1,200 Israelis were killed on October
7th and 136 remain hostage in response
27,485 of whom whom are women and
children and most gazin today cannot
reach a fully functioning hospital this
is not war this is Slaughter and yet
after all this destruction and
Devastation the N the Netanyahu
government is still nowhere close to
their stated objective of destroying
Hamas okay all the things that I want to
say about them will get us kicked off
YouTube and everywhere else which is why
we're on Rumble and locals but let me
just stay on YouTube okay fine they
understand nothing about war they're
lying about genocide there was a
ceasefire on October 6th and everything
else but the way I'm connecting that
psychotic over-the-top rhetoric to
everything else I'm talking about is
they've decided who the good guys and
bad guys are they also when when I say
they understand nothing about war to be
like well they killed x amount of your
people and look how many of people they
in a war when you want to win you got to
win you got to win that's just reality
and don't think that if given the
opportunity that Rashida TB and AOC
wouldn't wouldn't be happy to take out
all of their enemies and and God forbid
they ever get the power to do those
things so the point is why doesn't
someone like Mark cubin speak up against
these people on his own side when you
see Rashida Talib and AOC they're the
end result of a society that has pushed
forward Dei and the oppressed oppressor
narrative right he's afraid actually to
call people like them anti-semites which
they actually are and I don't say that
lightly how often on this show do
actually call someone an anti-semite but
every now and again you got to call a
spade a spade but there's another reason
for that and the reason for that is that
the left has also while they've done all
of this damage related to neo-racism
they've also to us told us repeatedly
for decades now that multiculturalism is
the most important thing right that if
we could just bring in more people and
if we could just all look like this
magical rainbow and all of those things
and no ideas are better than others and
none are worse than others that things
would be better except the problem is
there are people there are cultures that
behave a certain way that can actually
live with other cultures and there are
some cultures and ways of life that are
not congruent with other people and
we've done a pretty damn good job of it
for 200 plus years in the United States
of America with our Melting Pot but
these people are now poisoning the pot
we had a beautiful soup and they have
they have started to poison it so
attacking Dei harms the lefts implicit
aim to make this country and its
institutions basically into a giant
shell Corporation right like and and how
do we know this well look at their
stance on illegal immigrants they want
to just keep bringing them in so when I
say that they want to make the United
States a shell Corporation they don't
care about the founding ideas of this
country they don't care about the ideas
of freedom and Law and Order and all
those things they just want to bring in
more and more people to turn this
country into an upside down Banana
Republic which will do pretty well for
for them uh Liz Warren uh 1
1024th Native American Liz Warren who
said she was a Native American so she
could get a job at Harvard which is the
most like perfect progressive thing you
could ever do uh she went on quote
unquote comedian Steven colar show last
night to explain that she's not happy
about this border deal and you might
find that interesting why wouldn't
someone on the left be happy with the
Border deal well it's not doing enough
for the illegal immigrants and migrants
in fact it's it's actually the bill the
Republicans probably couldn't get under
other circumstances because it doesn't
have comprehensive immigration reform it
has border security well and so here's
the thing it's got some really good
pieces in it's got more resources for
the border which is good it's got in it
for example accelerated it's got work
permits in it so people who are here who
are trying to get Asylum actually would
be allowed legally to go get jobs and
that means yeah hey
taxes they could they could move out of
shelters they could pay taxes and look
at least back home in Massachusetts
there are a lot of employers who really
would like to have the extra help to
have the extra workers so there's some
good things in here I also want to say
there's some things that are really
missing here you remember back during
covid that one of the things we all
talked about were the essential workers
who kept us all going there was a lot of
undocumented workers and I work worked
on a bill with a lot of other people to
say let's create a path to citizenship
for these undocumented workers let's not
I don't want to bang a pan to say thank
you I actually want to say you have
helped save this nation you kept our
food supply going you kept our Medical
Care going kept our trash pickup going
we are grateful and we will show we are
grateful by creating the path to
citizenship interesting nothing about
actually having a border defending our
border who are these people and
everything else by the way Elizabeth
Warren's worth around $60 million I
don't know how many people she's giving
that money to so that they can go you
know you know buy homes and things like
that it's like share lady you're a
socialist share share but again this is
what they are doing instead of ever
talking about what would be good for
Americans it's always what's good for
those oh we'll give them a pathway to
citizenship we'll get them out of the
shelters it's like wait one thing at a
time lady how about have a border first
how about we figure out who these people
are and everything else and also Co was
a complete farce I I know if she knows
that maybe we should can we can we send
her an email on that we can get that to
her office and and the real farce
related to co of course was that they
told some of us that we are
non-essential and what is our
implication we needed we just needed
these illegals to be here to keep the
country going dur like it's all just
nonsense and it's done on a completely
farsal quote unquote comedy show but
they push this everywhere we showed you
this this is going to be a smaller
portion of a clip we showed you last
week from CNN uh explaining that uh this
analyst explaining that in New York City
you must have these illegals because how
could how else could we get food or gas
or anything else well it's so
complicated because you know you're a
New Yorker you move through the city
every day as I do we see these people we
touch these people they're out looking
for work they're delivering our food
they're at the gas stations and the car
wash um I mean these are people who came
in waves you know 170,000 probably to
New York City all right first off dude
stop in these people that's number one
number two what are you implying are you
implying that there aren't people in New
York City that want jobs that only
illegal people will deliver our food and
everything else and and if if you are
saying that are you saying you want to
well I guess we should then keep them in
those jobs forever none of it makes
sense the entire system is designed to
to eat itself so when I when I call it a
shell game it's like what what are we
what is anyone standing up for anymore
right you've got senators like Elizabeth
Warren defend you know standing up for
people who are not American you have
people like AOC and Rashida Talib
defending terrorists you have analysts
on CNN explaining that only illegals can
somehow deliver their food and these are
all thought of as the good guys let's go
back to Eric Adams because as you know
he created a as if New York City doesn't
have enough problem and hasn't has
enough of their tax base disappear he
found a cool 53 million uh so that could
give credit cards to illegals I maybe we
could all take a trip to New York City
after and pretend we're illegals and get
some cash let's see we're not giving
people American Express cards we are
giving them a food card so instead of a
debit card instead of having to deliver
food and have people eat food that we
were seeing waste in food they're now
able to get their own food I mean I
don't even know what he's talking about
and trust me there's a longer version of
it I didn't want to budge you with it
you are giving you are taking money from
your legal taxpayer base which again is
thinning out because everyone's leaving
New York and then you are giving it to
illegals so that how about you just say
to the illegals you can't stay here but
we know you're tolerant and you're
diverse and you're full of chocolate so
you want as many of these people as
possible and you want to do it on the
backs of your actual citizens but let's
continue because it's not just New York
City as I said it's been federalized and
it's expanding everywhere uh here is
treasury secretary Janet y this is just
yesterday explaining how immigration
contributes to the labor force she might
be kind of right but then we'll go a
little further after so um the growth in
the labor force is slowed and I would
say that at this point um immigration
actually contributes a substantial
amount to labor force growth as well so
um the population growth um with these
demographic Trends and immigration ation
are the main on shaping um labor force
growth and um that's part of the reason
why our economy um it looks like its
potential to grow at this point unless
there's a pickup in either labor force
growth or productivity looks to be in
the neighborhood or maybe a little bit
less than 2% which is really lower than
we're accustomed to by historical
standards okay I'm not going to pretend
that I'm the labor secretary or an
economic expert here but do you see the
way they're you it's a lot of double
speak everything that they do first off
There's no distinction between legal
immigration and illegal immigration
right if you come to America and you
come here legally and you work hard and
you have hopefully family members here
and and a path to a better life that's
what the whole freaking dream is all
about and and virtually everybody on
both sides of the aisle is for it but
they're confusing things right now where
she's in essence when she says we need
more immigration for the labor force
she's basically saying because she works
for Biden right she's in the Biden
Administration we need more of these
illegals to do a bunch of stuff like
deliver our food as the guy said before
except are you saying that everyone in
America has a job does everyone have
that good job already like it's just
nonsense but now I want to connect this
to uh something else because we've sort
of shown you the how they're trying how
they actually destroy companies and they
destroy cities and they destroy culture
with all of these bad ideas and what
does is at some point America has no
freaking idea what it is anymore right
we're just this thing that's why I said
shell company before we're just this
thing that exists as the middleman for
bad people to come in take what they can
and and move on and that is not good and
that is not what the founders intended
uh here's Tucker Carlson on the theovon
podcast talking about how through Wars
and Dei and the rest of it uh and
illegal immigration that America no
longer knows what it is why do we go
along with that consensus a lot of times
what is it that makes us afraid to speak
out like let's go over war with Ron it's
like what yeah and I just feel like I
have a moral obligation to say I I think
that's really unwise you don't want to
you don't want to go to war with Iran no
because I'm not insane that's insane oh
yeah look I'm not saying it is either I
don't think that we should be involved
in a lot of this you think how's it help
is it helping you a lot when I was a
child it felt like that we were all a it
felt like we were United we were all
like Americans I feel like that's been
pretty heavily compromised pretty
quickly even like America just feels
like a shell company yes that um people
just park their assets we're just in LLC
for for a lot of yeah have we always
been that of course not it was a real
country it wasn't just an idea or some
shell company or LLC that's so nice I'm
stealing that by the way I hope this
never airs so I can steal that
yeah one there one time I was talking to
Tucker on the phone years ago and I said
something about a protection racket that
the left is a protection racket right
you call everybody racist and then you
know it's a protection racket because
then basically they're afraid to turn it
on you because they know you'll turn it
on them and he said I'm going to steal
that I'm going to steal that and I was
like you can't steal that you got to
credit me goes I'm in cable news we
don't have to credit anybody because
it's kind of funny that he he openly
admits that that's kind of how the game
operates but anyway that that's a
sidebar the point is that all of these
bad ideas it leaves America as not much
of anything we go to Wars that we're not
sure why we're in the wars right we we
bring in people and we allow them to
suck our resources off that sounded
weird while we well you know the good
person gets screwed
but anyway here's Janet yelling you get
it so so America is no longer like it's
no longer an idea or it's no longer a
functioning country that the founding
ideas work right we've allowed all of
this stuff to come in and just take and
take and take and take and then what are
you left with you're left with a shell
company that doesn't really produce
anything but just kind of exists for
more people to to take from it uh
speaking of which they're constantly
while they're bringing in more of these
illegals right Janny Ellen wants to
bring in more to keep the labor force up
she also wants to uh make sure that uh
the government will be watching you
while you uh legally transact with your
friends and family however you might go
ahead doing that check this out at a
congressional hearing yesterday has
treasury including finsen or Federal
Banking agency like the FED FDIC OCC
instructed financial institutions to
search Americans legal transactions in
attempts to surveil their
purchases well we received a letter from
you I believe on this topic and we
intend to investigate fully into to
respond are you instructed banks
financial ins institutions to provide
this information
well fin
sin's job is to work with financial
institutions to make sure are they
instructing them financial institutions
to search Americans legal transactions
in attempts to surveil their
purchases I I promise a thorough look
into everything this is really
concerning lady are you the one who has
your job who might do something like
that so okay so we're getting a
non-answer as to whether the government
is telling your bank that it can look
into your financial transactions
nobody's doubting nobody's well I can't
say nobody's doubting you're allowed to
do with your money as you see fit and
you're allowed to buy things and and
you're allowed to lend money to people
and whatever else what why does the
government have allowed to put pressure
on banks so that they can just open up
the records on all of that and again I'm
connecting that to everything else
because they're constantly looking to
screw you right they want to take your
money and give 53 million in in credit
cards to feed these people while you are
doing whatever the hell it is that
you're doing and you have your right to
privacy and everything else and they
want to make sure that they can keep an
eye on you for that the next version of
of all of this of course is how they
will try to regulate uh crypto and
fortunately at least as it stands now
crypto which is endtoend encrypted
technology so if you send Bitcoin to
somebody uh and it goes from your
Bitcoin wallet to their coin while the
government has no way of regulating that
but they're working on it uh and here is
Janet Yellen explaining to Congress that
uh they have got to figure out a way to
do that because God only we can't have
these people just buying a sandwich for
a friend we're the government for God's
sakes council is focused on digital
assets and related risks such as runs
such as from runs on crypto asset
platforms and stable coins potential
vulnerab abilities from crypto asset
price
volatility and the proliferation of
platforms acting outside of or out of
compliance with applicable laws and
regulations applicable rules and
regulation should be enforced and
Congress should pass legislation to
provide for the regulation of stable
coins and of the spot market for crypto
assets that are not securities we look
forward to continuing to engage with
Congress on this with this overview I
look forward to taking your questions on
you get the point of all this why are
they constantly trying to find out more
about what you're doing and figuring out
more ways that they can regulate you and
tax you and make sure that you can't
send Bitcoin to a friend without them
knowing why you did it right and it has
nothing to do with oh because the
government's just looking out you might
be doing something mean and you might be
selling drugs and no no no no no you all
know it that's just the excuse to
control every little bit of your life
and then while they're doing that so
while they're bringing in illegals and
giving illegal stuff and checking out
all your finances and and taking your
tax dollars and everything else what are
they also trying to do well they're
constantly giving money to countries
that we have no freaking idea what
they're doing if they're not bombing
other countries uh here's a tweet from
yesterday Janet Yellen regarding the
bipartisan agreement that now is dead uh
that Joe Biden was pushing and as I said
yesterday on the show bipartisan just
means everyone's getting screwed uh she
retweeted President Biden she wrote
Congress should swiftly pass this
bipartisan agreement which Advance
advances the National Security of the
United States that includes by
sustaining budgetary support for Ukraine
which underpins their Valiant resistance
and weakens Putin's ability to further
threaten our NATO's allies and she's
retweeting the president who wrote or
obviously he is not allowed to hold a
phone or tweet uh but somebody wrote
this our bipartisan National Security
agreement allows the us to continue our
Vital work to stand up for Ukraine's
freedom and support its defense if we
don't stop Putin's appetite for control
he won't limit himself to just Ukraine
and the costs for America will rise Now
understand that in this bipartisan deal
that had something to do with our border
where they're going to let in 1.8
million illegals and a whole bunch of
nonsense and we already have all the
laws there was also another 60 billion
for Ukraine another 6 billion for
Ukraine and at the end of the day if we
give him another 60 billion and all of
the planes and all of the tanks and all
of everything else and we push Putin
into the corner as I have said from day
one of this war he's got the freaking
nukes so how is it that 60 billion gets
us over the hump that he just says okay
I'm out you
win think you understand that that's
actually not how uh it's going to work
so what is going on here with Ukraine
and I would disconnect that very
obviously from all of the lies that
Rashida t and AOC just said about Israel
Israel has an enemy on its border
they're not asking for troops or
anything else they're asking for
Military Support so they can stop a
genocidal organization from killing them
and by the way they still have American
hostages which nobody talks about it's
as opposed to Ukraine where it's very
unclear what the goals are we just keep
pouring more and more money and you
might go well what's that all about
check out this headline and you might
kind of figure it out Black Rock JP
Morgan and McKenzie working on you
Ukraine reconstruction bank so they are
going to put together a giant Bank you
understand these these giant
conglomerates that own all of these
assets and everything else and I'm not
even saying everything about them is
evil I'm just trying to show you what is
going on here the more that you UK the
more that Ukraine gets demolished and
destroyed the more that these companies
will come in for the Reconstruction and
somehow they will make a whole bunch of
cash let's go back to Congress one more
time uh because there was another
hearing yesterday uh and this is Josh
Holly pressing Global managing partner
of McKenzie and company over why they
and they're sort of like Black Rock and
these other companies why do they do
business with America's enemies like is
that good for America if we have these
giant corporations that do business with
say China and these other countries that
are undermining American values that
doesn't seem great does it my question
is why should you be able to get any
contracts to the United States
government if you're going to ADV
foreign Nations who are hostile to us
and make gobs of money off of them why
should you be getting US Government
contracts Senator we've never worked
with the Chinese Communist party or the
central government in China to the best
of my knowledge you're working with
state-owned Enterprises this is this is
China is not a democracy they own these
companies these companies are doing the
bidding of the Chinese military and
you're making money off of it hand over
fist my question is I guess if you want
to do that I I guess it doesn't violate
the law but I just wonder why is it that
you should then be able to turn around
and make $850 million in one year alone
off the American taxpayer I mean explain
that to me Senator um our work with the
federal government uh we stand behind uh
we bring well I'm sure you do it's
incredibly lucrative that's the problem
you make gobs of money off of our
enemies and then you turn around you
make gobs of money off of us it's
outrageous frankly you know I know a lot
of the Congressional stuff that we show
you it's a dog and pony show like not
much of it happens right we can expose
things but not much happens after but
that's a particularly good moment
because Holly's right when the when the
McKenzie guy they get government
contracts right so they get government
contracts from the United States so you
as a taxpayer you pay for these
government contracts for McKenzie to do
their reconstruction of Ukraine and all
these other things and then and then at
the same time they work with other
countries like China although he says
we've never worked with the Communist
party but as Holly points out Communist
party they own all of the the assets in
China all of these companies that you're
working with they own them so they're
taking from both and as again as Holly
points out it's like yeah maybe you can
get away with it but what do we stand
for in America or are we just a shell
company that really is the question so I
would say the point of all of this is
the more questions that you ask just
question the narrative think for
yourself and then maybe we can shift the
Paradigm so the big thing over uh the
last couple days is that Tucker Carlson
was spotted in Russia and people started
going my God is Tucker Carls going to
sit down with Putin now Putin has sat
down with Western journalists over the
years and yes it turns out that Tucker
the interview happened already right
they haven't aired it yet but it has
happened we believe yeah so it has
happened already they have not aired it
yet uh I certainly hope that Tucker uh
did not have to make concessions
beforehand what are you allowed to ask
what are you not allowed to ask I hope
that he will not edit it after and I
hope he didn't pull any punches that
will all remain to be seen and I hope he
will be as transparent as possible uh
but here he is explain explaining why he
sat down with Putin we're in Moscow
tonight we're here to interview the
president of Russia Vladimir Putin we'll
be doing that soon there risks to
conducting an interview like this
obviously so we thought about it
carefully over many months here's why
we're doing it first because it's our
job we're in journalism our duty is to
inform people 2 years into a war that's
reshaping the entire world most
Americans are not informed they have no
real idea what's happening in this
region here in Russia or 600 Mi away in
Ukraine but they should know they're
paying for much of it in ways they might
not fully yet
perceive this war has utterly reshaped
the global Military and trade alliances
and the sanctions that followed have as
well and in total they have upended the
world economy the post-world War II
economic order the system that
guaranteed prosperity in the West for
more than 80 years is coming apart very
fast and along with it the dominance of
the US dollar these are not small
changes they are history altering
developments they will Define the lives
of our
grandchildren most of the world
understands this perfectly well they can
see it ask anyone in Asia or the Middle
East what the future looks like and yet
the populations of the English-speaking
countes seem mostly unaware they think
that is nothing has really changed and
they think that because no one has told
them the truth they are fawning pep
sessions specifically designed to
amplify zelinsky's demand that the US
enter more deeply into a war in Eastern
Europe and pay for it that is not
journalism it is government propaganda
propaganda of the ugliest kind the kind
that kills people at the same time our
politicians and media Outlets have been
doing this promoting a foreign leader
like he's a new consumer brand not a
single Western journalist has bothered
interview the president of the other
country involved in this conflict
Vladimir Putin Americans have a right to
know all they can about a war they're
implicated in and we have the right to
tell them about it because we are
Americans too we are not here because we
love Vladimir Putin we are here because
we love the United States and we want it
to remain prosperous and free Elon Musk
to his great credit has promised not to
suppress or block this interview once we
posted on his platform X and we're
grateful for that Western governments by
contrast will certainly do their best to
censor this video on other less
principal platforms because that's what
they do they are afraid of information
they can't control but you have no
reason to be afraid of it we are not
encouraging you to agree with what Putin
may say in this interview but we are
urging you to watch it you should know
as much as you can and then like a free
Citizen and not a slave you can decide
for yourself
thanks isn't that kind of right now
again we we should know what the the uh
the regulations were that Putin and his
team were asking of Tucker so did they
say you can't talk about this you can
talk about this we get to take things
out and all that and I do hope Tucker
will be honest about that on the other
side you know you may remember that when
Tucker was still on Fox he did a
two-part interview with Kanye West and
it turns out that Tucker's team did edit
out some stuff that they didn't want out
there uh so so Tucker does not have a
perfect track record here so I just
putting that just put that in your
pocket and put that aside but the the
grander narrative that he's talking
about there should we know more about
what Putin's narratives are we are at
War I know we're not declared at War but
if you keep funding a war if you just
give them another 60 Bill and another 60
Bill and another 60 bill for other
people to fight you are at War right we
all kind of know that that that's
actually the truth we are watching the
sort of post-world War to World Order be
completely upended right now should we
not know more information directly from
the players it's not so that Putin can
get propaganda out it's wouldn't
wouldn't you have wanted to know if
there was an honest interviewer sitting
down with Hitler pre- World War II or in
the middle of World War II wouldn't you
want a good journalist to ask the right
question so more people could have known
what was really going on not as
propaganda but is truth so so about
asking questions is not bad uh being
brave you know Tucker's putting his butt
on the line here to go there he knows
this is going to have a cost for him
it'll have some upside as well Elon
knows it'll have a cost for him it'll
have some upside as well but that's the
only way we're going to shift the Nar
narrative and get out of this stuff and
by the way when you fight the good fight
you actually can shift The Narrative so
I want to bring this all home with the
video that Chris rufo uh put up you guys
know Chris rufo from the Manhattan
Institute he's been on the show a bunch
of times he has been the leader in
taking out Dei not only that but Claud
gay from Harvard basically stepped down
because rufo started doing research on
some of her plagiarism they found over
50 in instances of it she's no longer
the president of Harvard so this is a
guy who doesn't just talk about stuff he
goes ahead and does stuff and then you
actually shift The Narrative and once
you shift The Narrative then companies
countries and maybe the world order
start ordering themselves in a different
way wouldn't that be pretty
cool I am unveiling or revealing the
game as it actually
exists it's really a devil's bargain
that Executives have made to make sure
that their PowerPoints at the end of the
year look a little bit better on
demographics they are really hiring
people primarily by ideology Christopher
rufo is a bond villain narrating his own
evil plot I think tech companies are
uniquely positioned to eliminate their
Dei bureaucracies now that we're in a
place where people can stand up and just
say that's American greatness
American innovation and creativity the
principle of color blind equality the
idea of having a hierarchy of Merit
talent and virtue rather than
victimology so that guy who's fighting
against neoism and has done more to
destroy it than almost anybody else he's
thought of as the bad guy Tucker thought
of as the bad guy Elon thought of as the
bad guy are these the bad
guys that's for you to
decide speaking of bad guys I had a very
scary fell Ben Shapiro on the show part
one is up across platforms the full
things on locals already Ruben report.
locals.com that's where postgame show
will be in about 30 seconds as you know
new Twitter account Ruben report show
directly for our Clips uh we do now air
the first few minutes of this show on
Instagram and then we try to get you
guys to move over to the other platform
so you should follow us at Ruben report
we leave you with the elderly man
pretending to be president goodbye it is
not an
exaggeration uh were it not um for the
leadership of the NAACP for the men and
women who educated me uh when we'd sit
over in Reverend Wright's church as
we're talking about uh the segregating
the raldo and and the queen movie
theaters you remember Mouse those days
got involved in desegregating movie
theaters and helping you may remember
Reverend Moyer in Delaware and Herman
Holloway organized voter registration
drives coming out of black churches on
Sunday figuring how we're going to move
I'd go to 8:00 mass then I'd go to
Reverend herring's Church where we'd
meet in order to organize and figure
where we were going to go whether we're
going to desegregate the Realo movie
theater what we were going to do no I'm
serious it started a civil rights
movement I used to go to 7:30 mass then
to go to
10:00 CL 10 o' service with the Reverend
who was running the church is now the
bishop she's a bishop I was not an
activist I was not out marching I was
not down in Selma I was not anywhere
else
[Music]